european countries that do not uphold
human rights democracy and the rule of
law
risk losing access to eu funds but the
rules are still yet to be enforced
parliament is set to call for the
legislation to be immediately applied to
rule breakers 5g hardware
charging points for alternative fuels
and high-capacity digital
infrastructure are all vital components
of a modern green economy
members will vote on the 30 billion euro
connecting europe facility
set to improve the blocks into
connectivity
the european medicines agency has played
a vital role in ascertaining the safety
and effectiveness of covid19 vaccines
and treatments
helping steer europe out of the pandemic
parliament will vote on strengthening
the agency's mandate to be even better
prepared for future health crises
in recent years the eu has faced its
biggest migratory challenges since the
second world war
meps will vote on eu funds for common
asylum and migration policies
and on greater support for countries
with external borders
slovenia will present parliament with
its priorities for the next
six months as it takes over the
presidency of the council of the eu from
portugal